hey guys what's up we got a freak out
about areas I am so happy that he's
confirmed for the movie oh thank god for
toys so what's going on here is the toy
player happened this past week at the
Javad Center in New York that's where
New York comic-con is every year they
show off all kinds of toys from all the
merchandisers that do stuff for these
big movies not just for the DC people
but for Marvel everything else so I'll
talk about the Marvel stuff during the
Marvel videos that do because there's
some guardians of the galaxy that they
showed off we got to look at egos a
living planet there's all kinds of cool
shut up and take my money stuff that
you'll be able to throw your money at
later this year Ares though I feel like
this is a breath of relief everybody was
wondering about Ares in the Wonder Woman
movie he's such an important person for
her character that it would have been
weird for them to not include him in the
DC EU so I'm actually really happy about
this but if you're new to the channel I
do DC videos every week be sure to
subscribe to get everything there's
going to be a bunch of Wonder Woman
stuff happening and they even confirm
the Justice League trailers coming
really soon so I'll talk about that at
the end of the video but Ares most of
you if you read the new 52 or you played
in Justice there's like a couple
different versions of the characters
that we've seen lately in the last five
to six years the last big-screen version
of him was in the 2009 Wonder Woman
animated movie you might actually
recognize the person who's voicing this
is only within this prism diamonds the
true darkness that lurks in the hearts
of all men
you
arey
and God
do not see
I am more than a god I have a force of
nature you have a grass and shadow this
Diana is why we can never reunite with
the outside world better if you can
accept a nature of man as it is wicked
so even if you're not really familiar
with his powers his abilities because he
is a God he's a fully fledged God with
all the powers does that grant them in
the way that Wonder Woman is not she's
more of a demigod Ares is the son of
Zeus and Hera Wonder Woman is the
daughter of Zeus and Hippolyta I know
there's a couple different versions of
Wonder Woman's origin story but Ares is
usually the same so it doesn't really
change his powers the way they explain
her in the DC EU is that she can't fly
and in the trailer she does say that she
has no father but technically her father
is Zeus he helped give life to her so
she does kind of have a father but it
gets really trippy so they're kind of
mixing and matching the comic-book
backstory so don't worry you don't have
to read like every single Wonder Woman
comic book that ever happened because
Ares is actually pretty consistent just
in the way that his powers work where he
comes from what he can do but the really
interesting thing about him in this
movie is it looks like he's operating
behind the scenes so here's where we get
into like Harry Potter other Warner
Brothers IP stuff so supposedly David
Thewlis from the Harry Potter movies or
most of you remember him from those
movies he's done a lot of other stuff
but he's the one that's being credited
as Ares because he doesn't sound like
he's seven feet tall in this hooking
Schwarzenegger like dude what might end
up happening is is because Ares can take
whatever form that he wants is that
he'll start out looking like a normal
person and then eventually we'll get to
final boss form
[Music]
[Applause]
video game logic that Wonderwoman faces
her final boss he has three different
forms so she better watch out I know
does that moment in the trailer where it
seems like she's flying there's like
that big weapon that's going off
they said that this is going to test the
limits of her abilities she's actually
going to see the full extent of her
powers but just because when Batman V
Superman came out they said that Wonder
Woman in this universe doesn't fly I
don't think that she's actually flying
at this moment something else is going
on she's jumping really high but it's
her solo movie so it just makes sense
that they're going to run the gamut up
this is where she comes from this is
what she can do this is where she's
headed in the future these are the
things that happened to her that shaped
the way that she thinks these are the
big villains that she's faced like that
throwaway line from Batman V Superman
that was so cool where she says I've
killed things that are not from this
earth she might be talking about Ares
because even though he's a god and you
can't kill God wait for it you can
actually kill gods in the comics like
Geoff Johns did that big run called
Darkseid war where the new gods were
killed off and the Justice League got
their powers for a brief period and they
became gods themselves till those powers
were taken away
of course you're selling toys for Wonder
Woman you want people to buy them you're
going to sell the coolest version of the
character so it looks like the design
that they've gone with is modern era
like post-crisis in slight mix with
injustice because a lot of the costumes
a lot of the universe does draw some of
the aesthetic from the injustice
universe even though that's not the
story they're going with I always get a
lot of questions about injustice ever
since they debuted that armored looking
flash costume last year I've gotten so
many questions about the injustice
universe are they doing that in the
movies is that what the DCU is not
exactly they're just borrowing the
aesthetics of that just because it looks
so much more hardcore it's like the idea
of Marvel's ultimate universe a more
hardcore version of the family-friendly
Marvel Universe the basic synopsis for
Ares reads very Greek tragedy so you
guys will like this this is actually a
translation so it's like 99% accurate
but it says why does ooze create the
Amazons Ares is one of the biggest hits
in the world to restore harmony between
them Zeus created the Amazons that Ares
reduced to slavery
the Amazons revolt with the help of Zeus
who will die at the hands of his son
having had time to find Samus Kira their
Haven of peace
Diana Prince becomes Wonder Woman by
helping Steve Trevor in a squad of proud
armed
in law in search of one who wants to
white humanity off the map with deadly
gas so that confirms a couple things
that we've seen from the trailers Aries
is helping to destroy humanity through
Danny Houston's character who's sort of
like the middle boss they're using small
boss dr. Poisson to develop this special
gas during World War one
to kill off everyone Ares himself
actually feeds off of war it makes him
stronger negative emotion so the more
people fight the stronger he gets
and he actually just his presence can
make people want to fight so even just
standing around in a crowd of people
it's really cool so you get the idea
from this backstory is that a lot of
people are worshipping Ares who's super
popular but it's leading to the downfall
of humanity so Zeus tries to help them
by creating the Amazons to make peace
but then there's a big revolt Ares ends
up killing his father very Greek tragedy
in the Amazons are hiding out on Stannis
Kyra so that Ares can't get to them so
everybody just wade out for finalboss
form areas it's going to be a great
battle for Wonder Woman and it'll be
interesting to see how they incorporate
the God into the future DC EU movies my
guess is is it just because there's a
lot of similarities in the way that
Steppenwolf looks in the comics to Ares
is is that Ares is the warm-up for
Steppenwolf in Justice League in the
minions of Darkseid because if you
thought that one God was bad what about
a whole squad of em that are almost as
powerful it just be complete nightmare
which is why you need the Justice League
and those are the nightmares that
Batman's been having but there's also a
bunch of Justice League mother box stuff
that's happening that I'll talk about in
a separate video they updated the
synopsis for Justice League just to be a
little more direct about why Darkseid
wants to attack the earth what
Steppenwolf is going to be doing like
what's the point of all this so it's all
about mother boxes I'll do a video about
that later this week let me know in the
comments what do you guys think about
Ares how do you want them to use them in
the future movies it sounds like if he
doesn't die he's just going to slink
back to the shadows but what can happen
later tonight is I'll post my Flash
gorilla City episode after it airs so
that's going to be crazy and I'm also
thinking about taking a day of the week
to always to DC videos for the movies
for the comics so let me know which
you want me to do that on like I have
Star Wars Fridays I want to pick another
day or two for different things like
I'll have a day that I just do
spider-man videos so let me know which
day of the week like maybe Thursdays or
Fridays along with Star Wars that I
always do DC stuff they give away
because this is such a big deal there's
a new round of the injustice to give
away I'm giving away a copy of the game
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
congratulations to last week's injustice
giveaway winner cow sip please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details so new
flash postin later tonight I'll see you
guys when I post that video everyone
looks high-five well you wait for that
you can click here to learn all about
rod and you can click here to learn all
about that mystery Marvel name or
project